Donald Trump is now openly begging for
money in an orange conspiracy rant and a
bunch of his loser followers are giving
him the money why would you give a
supposed billionaire a little bit of
cash because of his claim that he's
getting arrested well we'll get to that
this is an unbelievable video
unbelievable video called dismantle the
Deep State and reclaim our democracy
we'll remind you what the Deep state is
but this is open conspiracy stuff from
the failed former president it is scary
it is dystopian and it is where we are
in 2023 shockingly so take a listen to
this from agenda 47. here's my plan to
dismantle the Deep State and reclaim our
democracy from Washington corruption
remember he's a former president the
idea now of oh I'm I'm an outsider and
dude you were the president of the
United States how are you an outsider of
any kind once and for all and Corruption
it is
first I will immediately reissue my 2020
executive order restoring the
president's authority to remove Rogue
bureaucrats and I will wield that power
very aggressively remember what that is
is about being able to fire
government employees who are outside the
immediate political realm like secretary
of state right new president comes in
you replace the Secretary of State but
what Trump wants because he believes
that every random employee of the state
department or at least I'm sorry of the
federal government uh including the
state department and others is against
him he wants to be able to come in and
just say fire tens of thousands of
people Insanity in terms of the
disjointed Interruption that it would be
to the way so many government
departments function second we will
clean out all of corrupt actors in our
national security and intelligence
apparatus what he means by that is
intelligence agencies don't seem to
agree with Trump's unhinged lies and so
he wants to get him out of there and
there are plenty of them
the Departments and agencies that have
been weaponized will be completely
overhauled so that faceless bureaucrats
will never again be able to Target and
persecute conservatives which they
weren't doing
political enemies which they're doing
now at a level that nobody
no possible
third we will totally reform Pfizer
courts which are so corrupt that the
judges seemingly do not care when they
are lied to
in warrant applications this is a
personal grievance of trump this is
grievance politics Trump doesn't like
that there was enough evidence against
some of the people in his 2016 campaign
such that fisa warrants were signed by
judges that he's like just change the
process so many judges have seen so many
applications that they know were wrong
or at least they must have known they do
nothing about it they're lied to Fourth
to expose the hoaxes and abuses of power
that have been tearing our country apart
we will establish a Truth and
Reconciliation Commission to declassify
and publish all documents on deep State
spying censorship and Corruption now
this this talking point we looked at and
on a different day which Trump is now
repeating truly orwellian very often we
people say orwellian and it's not
orwellian this is orwellian and there
are plenty of them fifth we will launch
a major Crackdown on government leakers
who collude with the fake news to
deliberately we false narratives and to
subvert
our government and our democracy and as
I told you yesterday
extraordinarily chilling in terms of
what it means for journalism and then we
get to the begging for money 100
000 government positions could be moved
out and I mean immediately of Washington
to places filled with Patriots who love
America and they really do love America
ninth I will work to ban Federal
bureaucrats from taking jobs at the
companies they deal with and they
regulate so they deal with these
companies and they regulate these
companies and then they want to take
jobs from these companies doesn't work
that way such a public display cannot go
on and it's taking place all the time
like with big Pharma finally I will push
a constitutional amendment to impose
term limits on members of Congress this
is how I will shatter the Deep State and
restore government that is controlled by
the people and for the people really
crazy 10 point plan thank you very much
yeah so this was sent out in a
fundraising email and we're going to get
to the fundraising aspect in a moment
let's actually discuss the Deep State
thing just for a moment for those who
aren't familiar with it the Deep state
conspiracy theory is again one of these
elitist cabal type conspiracy theories
the idea is government officials Elites
rich people transnational
Elites of different kinds they're
operating behind the scenes to
manipulate and control world events it
often implies that these individuals are
doing so against the interests of the
general public and that they are
responsible for many of the world's
problems now there's very little
evidence to support the existence of a
deep state
speculation
conjecture
misinterpreting isolated incidents or
events
what is true is that as a general
concept rich people and corporations
wield lots of power in Western societies
that's true
they go way further into this
puppeteer-like conspiracy unified
coordinated group of individuals and the
truth of course is that there are
agendas and there are competing
interests in government out of
government in the U.S in Europe in
different parts of the world oftentimes
deep state conspiracy
overlaps with globalist conspiracy One
World Government New World Order and all
of it is dripping in anti-Semitism that
Trump is now regularly and openly
claiming he's going to fight the Deep
state which has it in forum is really
wacky when it comes to remembering that
this is a former president but here's
the crazy part it's working to get
people to give them money Trump's fans
sent him a million and a half dollars in
three days after he falsely claimed he'd
get arrested Tuesday and that Soros and
the Deep state had it in for them let's
talk about that next Imagine for a
second that you try logging into your
email account only to find that your
password was changed an hour ago and
then you get notifications of activity
from your bank and then your credit
cards that is what identity theft is
like and it's a horrible feeling and we
dealt with it at the show not that long
ago but now I have an app called Aura
which gives me much more peace of mind
our sponsor Aura is the all-in-one
solution for keeping your online account
safe because Aura will scan the dark web
for your personal info passwords social
security number and you get fast alerts
when they find something you also get
fast alerts about credit inquiries Aura
protects all of your devices from
malware or even requests the removal of
your info from data broker sites and
Aura helps you manage what your kids can
do on their devices you can restrict
certain apps set screen time limits set
Focus times when you need them off of
devices go to aura.com Pacman to try it
free for seven days your login
credentials might already be floating
around out there and Aura will tell you
instantly for free the link is down
below